it's easy to pick the best and worst
lines in Game of Thrones the true
challenge lies in going through the
landfill that is the last two seasons of
the show and trying to find the gems
amidst the garbage so I'm going to try
my best to pick the greatest lines in
season 7 and 8 number 20 respect is how
the young keep us at a distance so we
don't remind them of an unpleasant
truth what is
that nothing lasts so initially I
thought this line was pretty deep and
clever but then I realized that it
doesn't seem that realistic I don't know
anyone who necessarily distances
themselves from old people and this kind
of line shines a negative light on them
like sure they can remind you of the
unpleasant truth of Aging but they offer
so much more like wisdom that comes from
that age from a more pessimistic
perspective this line Rings true so I'll
give it that at least and it's obviously
better than the absolute mediocrity of
the rest of the dialogue in the later
Seasons at least it made me Ponder the
meaning of of this line to some degree
instead of the dialogue instantly
evaporating from my memory with zero
impact number 19 I know
death he's got many
faces I look forward to seeing this one
this is just a simple line that I don't
think needs a lot of explanation it
thematically gels really well with
arya's character given her consistent
relationship with the concept of death
and I like how she phrases wanting to
meet the night King as him being another
one of death's many faces that and
maisy's delivery of the line is so cool
and badass so yeah I don't think I need
to explain this much further so let's
move on number 18 you want a [__] by
one you want a
queen and Okay this may seem like a
controversial pick by even including
this line due to how cringey the
delivery of it may be but the line
itself I think is fine to good on one
hand I like the mcal structure of these
two lines and the contrast it generates
along with it being an empowering line
for Cersei that Len HEI essentially
gives her all since this is the only
decent line of dialogue she gets all
season but on the other it feels like
David and Dan are trying really hard to
get this line onto a t-shirt it seems as
though they're trying to get Twitter
girls to go crazy over this line and use
it as a mantra or something which I
think happened briefly so because of
that it kind of breaks my immersion
whenever Cersei says this line but it
made an impact for a reason it's a solid
line that's unfortunately weighed down
by different aspects it has the same
energy as I drink and I know things
where it seems like David and Dan tried
really hard to make an iconic line
however I like cersei's line more than
Tyrion in season 6 number 17 you think
our house words are stamped on our
bodies when we're born and that's who we
are then I'd be Fire and Blood too this
line isn't anything special by any means
but I think it offers a decent
Counterpoint to Tyrion and everyone's
perspective perspective of being
prejudiced towards Danny for being a
Targaryen and the reason why I wouldn't
say this is a good Counterpoint is
because it's not necessarily the house
words but more because she has access to
nuclear weapons and she's starting to go
off the rails mentally that in this line
doesn't really apply to most houses
because they're normally positive
sayings but at the very least David and
Dan actually utilize a literary device
for this line in saying that house words
are stamped onto someone's body which to
me generally elevates lines because
literary devices or figures of speech
Elevate the creativity of writing the
first four seasons are filled to the
brim with literary devices like an
example being well my brother has his
sword and I have my mind and a mind
needs books like a sword needs a wet
stone so in general literary devices
bring lines out of a mediocre level and
imbue them with wit so that's kind of
why I'm including this line since DAV
and Dan's literary device usage was
almost non-existent throughout the later
Seasons number 16 tell them winter came
for house Fray similar to AR's last line
This is a simple but effective line the
main reason why I'm including it is
because she uses the word winter over
other more generic words like death or
misery winter instead is a clever way of
still saying that while also being a
thematic word relating to the Starks so
with this line she's essentially
communicating in a smart way that the
Starks have taken revenge on the phrase
again this is at 16 because of how
simple it is and I don't think it can
really be higher number 15 I don't plan
on knitting by the fire while men fight
for me I think this is a classic line
for lyana Mormont it's pretty much the
embodiment of her badass Persona and
communicates a strong feminist message
through this single line it's not
elevated by any good word play but I
really like the snappiness of this line
and how it immediately makes Lord Glover
shut up to me it feels like an
empowering line that instantly changes
the opinions of every Lord about whether
or not women should fight in the long
night although you could also probably
attribute that to Lazy writing and that
this point of potential debate ends
right away everyone just accepts woman
having to fight in the Great War it
seems like this could be a point of
conflict but hey that's just overall
writing it doesn't actually affect the
quality of the single line number 14
duty is the death of love I feel kind of
dirty for even including this line
because it's essentially cheating on
David and Dan's part they literally
reverse one of the best lines in the
earlier seasons and call all a day but
on a technicality it's a good line I'm
just not going to put this line any
higher because of how cheap it feels and
the reason why I'm not putting it lower
is because narratively it actually fits
well here because Jon's duty of needing
to kill the Mad Queen is inherently the
death of love so in a way it's kind of
used literally tying is communicating in
a smart way what Jon needs to do to save
The Realm by reversing his quotes it
works well in this moment but this line
obviously has the baggage of just
slightly changing up an old hit it and
re-releasing it and even then I'd still
put it over most other lines of dialogue
in the later Seasons number 13 she's
always been good at using the truth to
tell lies now this is a good line but I
really can't think of that many examples
of Cersei using the truth to tell lies
she mostly just flat out lies to people
or using the truth as a base point to
fabricate lies like what most people do
although they are referring to Cersei
using the truth of her being pregnant
and our hero is expecting her to Value
her life life but she lies about helping
against the night King so it's
technically true and the reason why I'm
putting this line higher than others is
because of the solid oxymoron she uses
truths to tell lies which is an
interesting way to phrase that statement
due to those words being opposites DAV
and Dan could have communicated this
line of dialogue in a much more generic
way but I'll give them credit here that
it works well still though I don't want
to give them too much credit because
it's an okay line amongst a bunch of
terrible ones number 12 the Lord of
light's going to wonder why I brought
you back 19 times just to watch you die
when I Chuck you over this [__] wall
between a lot of different characters I
think sander Cain still has some really
funny lines in the later Seasons now
there's kind of a balance in that should
I be prioritizing Wittier lines that are
smarter or should I also include some
clever usages of humor and I think that
balance pretty much rests on the fact as
to how funny the line of dialogue is and
how smart of an insult it is which to me
I think this line is pretty much perfect
for the Hound his pure annoyance towards
baric is always fun to watch and him
threatening to ruin his ultimate
importance in the long night by chucking
him over a wall is priceless I just
imagine the Lord of light malting in the
sky that and I didn't even realize it
but the Hound actually uses a hyperbole
by saying baric was brought back 19
times when it was actually six so that
aids the humor even more overall a
classically funny Hound line and I tried
my best to pick his more clever insults
instead of him just cursing at people
number 11 sometimes nothing is the
hardest thing to do honestly I think
this is a really good piece of advice
however I think tyan is in the wrong for
saying it at this point in the story
since he's essentially advising Danny to
let Jon sjora and other important
figures to die and the army of dead up
until this point don't have any counter
measures against a dragon so
theoretically Danny should not be in any
danger and it's really weird how Ty is
giving her this terrible advice but
going back to the actual line this is
something that says that has some form
of intelligence to it people often times
get antsy and will make blunders if they
don't thoroughly think about their
actions so doing nothing sometimes can
be very important or the option to
choose to do nothing can also be vital
in certain scenarios it's just kind of
unfortunate that turn is using it at a
completely bad time although in
hindsight he was technically right since
the nikin got a dragon so sure that was
the correct decision number 10 your lips
are moving and you're complain
complaining about something that's
whinging this one's been killed six
times you don't hear him about it in
terms of sheer quality of dialogue I'd
say this is partially inferior to
sandor's last quote at number 12 however
I think this is a genius insult towards
Gendry winging it perfectly highlights
the contrast and temperament of gendry's
whiny childlike response to the
situation by comparing him to a grizzled
warrior it stops Gendry dead in his
tracks as he re-evaluates his entire
attitude from the single line delivered
by the Hound it's also funny how they're
making fun of Gendry for reasonably
being upset for almost dying but these
men are so badass that he comes across
as a child which this line perfectly
captures that Dynamic that and like
usual Rory mcan's delivery is always
Immaculate and you simultaneously feel
the savageness and pure irritation
exuding from his voice number nine the
Lords of Westeros are sheep are you a
sheep
no you're a
dragon be a dragon this is technically a
few sentences but I'll bundle them
together into one overall line that
communicates a single point in terms of
word play this is a pretty basic line
and comparing people to animals has been
done in the past and obviously better
but at least DAV and Dan use a small
ounce of creativity of calling commoner
sheep and Danny a dragon which honestly
isn't impressive but the line carries a
lot of weight because of the
significance of its implic
Elena is trying to convince Danny to
ascend and become her true self and I
think this line is a great conduit for
that point along with di rig having
perfect line delivery in every scene
she's in which also probably elevates
this line for me just her saying be a
dragon alone is Iconic and badass number
eight kill a few hundred people they
make you a lord kill a few thousand they
make you King and then all your
[__] grandsons can ruin the
family with their [__] way I'm
honestly kind of torn on this line
because the first half I really enjoy
but the second half I think is inferior
and is still communicating the same
point and I technically should include
it so addressing the second half first
David and Dan regularly devolved into
the lazy insults of [__] jokes which
utterly lack any creativity this is also
kind of weird because David and Dan have
written some good insults in the later
seasons and then we have Braun who is
constantly saying [__] every other line
[__] [__] [__] cockless Maybe there's a
weak link between the two D's so braon
saying [__] Grandsons in
[__] ways I think is a lazy way
to write the line besides that though I
really like the statement that Braun
makes here especially how he phrases his
first sentence in that most of these
rich families have been established from
Mass Carnage and sheer violence an
example being the targaryens essentially
being nobody's in Westeros and then they
rode in with their dragons and rocked
most of the population then they turn
into the strongest house in Westeros so
I think Braun RAC is an interesting
topic through this line and is a good
Counterpoint about how Jim is
gatekeeping Braun from wanting to become
a powerful Lord even though this moment
is still devoid of logic since the show
acts like there's no other Lords that
exist in the reach number seven it's my
[__] luck I end up with a band of
fire worshippers now this may not be a
juicy insult but I absolutely love the
sheer irony of this statement it's just
really funny to me how sandor a man
whose fear in life is fire ends up with
Lord of Light fanatic so this line I
think calls out a funny scenario that
you may not have really been thinking
about there's not much else about this
line that's special since it's a quick
funny ironic statement but hey every
line doesn't need to be that long number
six if I ever saw you I cannot cut you
in half it'll take you a while with a
sparring
sword now I know that quite a few of
these last lines have been leaning
towards humor but I'd argue that it's
easier to do humor than it is making
intelligent lines with creative usages
of literary devices but I actually
really like this line from tyrian and
it's both a smart way to ease the
tension between him and his brother and
it's also pretty funny for a moment the
single line from Tyrion actually made me
think he was Tyrion from the earlier
Seasons a character who is quick sharp
and funny and this kind of line I think
perfectly suits him it's a great
response that serves multiple purposes
while also making it seem like Trin was
actually himself again so that's why I
put it this High number five The Perils
of self
ENT yeah this is the most popular good
line from season 8 that you were
probably waiting for although honestly
it feels kind of overrated because of
how simple it is and the fact that the
statement made by this line isn't that
deep but there's really not much else
competition for good lines after going
through the entirety of season 7 and 8
again so I guess this is the start of
our top five but to give the line some
credit self- betterment in general is an
arduous task even though it may not seem
like that sometimes and because of this
I think the line is inherently an
oxymoron and that something that's seen
as a positive can be a Peril to go
through then from a character
perspective it acts a good payoff for
both of these characters who have made
massive Transformations into better
people number four but then Mormont saw
them and you saw them and I trust the
eyes of an honest man more than I trust
what everybody knows initially I thought
this was a line that Tyrion said in
season 2 episode 2 where Jor Mormon
sends him the Raven about needing more
men but he doesn't actually say this and
it still feels like I heard this line
somewhere else so since I'm losing my
mind and I can't find a place of origin
then I guess stav and Dan actually came
up with it and if I'm wrong then this
line gets sent down 10 spots similar to
tyrion's clever and funny remark towards
Jamie this is a rare later season moment
where tyan could be interchangeable with
his earlier season self putting your
trust in honest people and ignoring the
noise of public knowledge that is
sometimes Twisted into being
misinformation is actually a good of
wisdom honorable people can be more
reliable for information and overall
this is a good and smart Tyrion line I
would put it much higher if it actually
utilize some kind of figure of speech
and David and Dan tried harder but at
least it was witty number three give us
common folk One Taste of power were like
the lion who tasted man nothing is ever
so sweet again honestly this line
completely took me by surprise because I
didn't even remember this was said by
varus probably because the scene was
overshadowed by Danny and John's meeting
but I was kind of dumbstruck that David
and Dan actually used the simile for
once although I wouldn't say it was
particularly outstanding and still
wouldn't crack the Brilliance of the
earlier Seasons but hey it's still good
the main reason why I wouldn't put this
line higher is the meaning behind it
it's a pretty simple statement of if you
give someone power then they want more
of it like that's an obvious thing that
people know and at the very least the
line itself was finally elevated by a
literary device of calling the common
folk the line that tastes man so good
job I guess number two inconfidence
should not be rewarded with blind
loyalty there is two for two baby
backtack lines now this line may not
include a strong usage of a figure of
speech but I think this is a really good
line that is smart is very in character
for Varys and exposes a great topic for
the nature of serving kings and queens
because there are so many characters
like it's stuck in serving competent
Kings like that's kind of the tragedy of
Varys in that he's a very skillful
servant but every King he served has
either been insane or not caring about
ruling Varys with this line basically
strikes Daenerys with a blunt Hammer Of
Truth and makes her realize that he in
fact is even more loyal to her because
he genuinely believes in her as long as
she's competent and his serving the
realm then that in turn breeds
unbreakable loyalty so to me this is
varys's Best Line in the later seasons
and I actually think this is V's last
good scene in the show as well number
one there are always lessons and fails
vales
yes you must be very wise by now this
may be a little underwhelming if you
were expecting some kind of intellectual
big IQ line but those fundamentally
don't exist in the later Seasons so I
have to make do but this line from Alena
was such a genius and devastating insult
that it genuinely floored me I think
it's by far one of the most clever lines
in season 7 and 8 and I think it easily
cuts the deepest just with these few
words she states how much of a failure
Jamie is and it's also done with a
sarcastic Twist of the line
superficially seeming like a compliment
a perfect line for Alena as a character
that is more subtle and communicated
with a delicious amount of sass also
this kind of insult isn't as
bombastically annoying as other more
crude insults that David and Dan WR like
I love the Hound spouting vitriolic
insults but they normally lack
creativity since D and Dan just slap a
couple curse words together or ter n
Bron says [__] and starts laughing as if
they come up with comedy gold so yeah
this is my favorite favorite line and
you can probably argue for the few lines
before this being better but honestly I
don't think really any of the quote
unquote intelligent lines are that good
after going through all of season 7 and
8 I thought there would be some better
hidden gems but this was really the best
set there was it's really sad that
there's this huge of a disparan quality
of writing probably because we're
dealing with a worldclass writer and
then two mediocre screenwriters but even
then David and Dan had years to write
these scripts and had brilliantly
complex characters at the disposal so
I'm kind of surprised that they couldn't
write anything better for these
characters it seems like a lot of
dialogue is rushed into just being used
as a device to quickly move the plot
forward instead of a wonderful tool to
investigate these characters in great
depth God damn what it diservice to
these characters and us thank you for
watching and my letter box patreon and
Discord link are in the description and
let me know in the comments if I miss
any lines from the later Seasons that
you liked or what your favorite is also
thank you so much to Logan Farmer for
being a Monumental Patron and unlocking
the tear of me shouting him out thank
you so much